wundervoll war luca schon immer so dumm
ich glaube damit ist so tollpatschig
gemeint so wie beispielsweise der schule
wo ich mir mein ohr da war ich eine wand
gelaufen hatte luca jemals so eine phase
mit einem komischen hasst ihr
kleidungsstil et cetera natürlich ganz
schrecklich wo ich die ware so dieses
brett vorm kopf vertraut luca dir vieles
an mag die alpakas so gern dass er sich
einen friseur gemacht hat mit der
aussieht wie ein
wie würde luca heißen wenn da ein
mädchen geworden wäre
[Musik]
birgit luka anstrengender als seine
schwester einfach nein einfach nein
willst du anonym bleiben oder möchte
lukas wir sind jetzt hier nicht zusammen
vor der kamera oder auch als wird das
buch für mich zusammen geschrieben haben
in dem buch war es ja auch so war er
papa oder mama kind also eindruck würde
ich sagen erst ein paar kind weil ich
durfte youtube eigentlich nicht machen
und du warst aber er offen was das alles
angehen und papa war er so nena ist luca
als kind beziehungsweise jugendlicher
gern klamotten shoppen gegangen
nein nicht wirklich
aber wenn er was haben wollte dann
natürlich immer irgendwie da musste dass
das auch sein wenn du überhaupt also
schaut mal war ich bei jack and jones
und hier über das gleiche getragen was
war das witzigste was lueg ag angestellt
hat als ich bei der grundschule
das rennen hatte gegen dominik und dann
bin ich über diese platte gestellt und
mit dem knie gegen die glastür von der
schule und da konnte keiner die schule
rein wegen mir also willst du hast mit
deinem damenrad geliehen und ich musste
schnell war die ampel fahren wollte gas
geben und es mir mitten auf der kreuzung
das fahrrad durchgebrochen die
wahllokale in seiner pubertät kleiner
rebell fragezeichen wie jungs halt sind
in der pubertät
ich denke ganz normal also nicht jetzt
so rebellisch harald schwarz gefärbt
oder metal musik oder vier chancen
so wandert luca seinen ersten zahn
verloren haben wir jemals so zahn bei
mir so richtig gezogen irgendwie somit
irgendwie so einem seil irgendwie damit
eine tür oder so bei lucca in der schule
gut dass ich mit hilfeleistungen waren
eigentlich immer ganz okay und immer
sehr pflichtbewusst immer alles gerne
gemacht und die schule geschwänzt werden
in welchem beruf hat dich deine mama
eigentlich gesehen also eigentlich
irgendwie gar nicht was wie kamt ihr auf
den namen luca
geschäftspartner in süddeutschland und
der hatte irgendwie kontakte mit italien
werde auf jeden fall sein kind vitali
schon mal so genau ich hatte mir damals
tatsächlich ein italienisches vornamen
buch gekauft und wir fanden irgendwie
italienischen namen klingen doch cool es
damals mal so gespräch war auch der neue
teil hingegen wegen das musste ich gar
nicht nein das wusste ich nicht auch
tatsächlich gemacht nicht als wohin denn
genau war ich überhaupt geplant
ja warst du auf irgendeine weise froh
als ich ausgezogen bin erst eigentlich
ja nicht gedacht hast du sofort weg
gehst
ich hätte gedacht dass das hier so unter
normalen länger genießen
direkt nach dem abi nahezu weg gegangen
im monat später oder so ob sich etwas
verbessert hat würde ich nicht sagen
so wie lange musste meinen po erwischen
immer noch würde mal sagen so vierte
klasse sowas ist lukas lieblingsspielen
duale frühere fifa wie waffen
es fing an mit kinderspielen mit diesen
wahllokalen seinen teenager jahren
kriminell unterwegs saß im knast musste
ich nicht abholen die polizei stand auch
nicht vor der tür ich hab mal
unterschriften gefälscht
in der grundschule was ist das häufigste
was du mir auf einen klebezettel
geschrieben hast
du hast selber immer diese kz im
kühlschrank jetzt auch ein neuer sarahs
vogelfutter martin vogel hört das häufig
so was du mir auf dem zettel geschrieben
hat jeden fall nicht zimmer aufräumen
manchmal eigentlich immer aufgeräumt
vielleicht stimmen dass katharina was
war lukas erstes wort war luca ein
braver junge mit circa vier bis acht
jahren das komplette jahr
wie finden sie es dass lucca so berühmt
ist auf der einen seite ist man
natürlich stolz muss ich sagen aber auf
der anderen seite erhält man auch immer
bedenken ja ich war ständig schwierige
frage sie haben ja auch ganz viele
nachteile oder das weiß auch luca selbst
am eigenen leibe zu spüren donnert er
aufgehört windeln zu tragen mit 3 1 und
machte seinen weihnachtsbaum hast du
überhaupt darf man sich nicht mal wie
steht ihr also den papa zu lukas
mentalen gesundheitsproblem ich glaube
damit sind einfach nur die panikattacken
gemein weil von mehr als ich jetzt so
ist lukas selbstständig oder braucht er
oft hilfe also locker kann sowas von
selbständig sein so wenn er möchte und
man allein ist aber solange irgendwelche
leute in der nähe sind da so hast du das
machst du das mal ich kann das nicht
dann kann ich auf einmal gar nichts wie
kann man seine schöne tochter haben aber
ein loch als sohn ja man könnte das war
eine rhetorische letzte frage schaust du
lukas videos das ist immer interessant
wenn ich dann mal leute treffe und wir
zufällig
ja wissen die oft mehr wie ich mein sohn
luca der schickt mir auch die links
nicht obwohl mich da das eine oder
andere mal interessiert dass ich sie
jeden tag x videos schicken weiß dass
ich stolz auf dich bin ja dann kriegst
du demnächst einmal jährlich zu
unterlegen
danke dir für das beantworten der fragen
und frohe weihnachten
[Musik]